ex-navy seal uh
credited with killing osama bin laden he
was uh
people got angry with him on twitter
because he was bragging about not
wearing a mask he took a selfie
with a uh a marine behind him or a guy
in a marine cap who had a mascot and he
goes i'm not a [ __ ] like this guy
and people gotta tell me that's a risky
move
risky and then risky to tweet about it
yeah that's brave to tweet about it i
almost wonder if he was tweeting out of
like trying to get back at the guy uh i
think it's the rivalry between seals and
marines
oh i could see a little bit of that yeah
okay okay well this goes really into
recently i
had i i saw a dang man in the um
in a marine's hat and i thought it said
mariners on it seattle mariners
and so i'm asking them about ichiro and
you know all of these different guys and
ken griffey jr and all this [ __ ] and the
guy is looking at him like i
am a damn and it said marines and not
mariners
he looks at me like i'm a damn still in
school adult you know
and uh so it was it was the most awkward
thing ever
but dude i think if you kill bin laden
dude i don't think you got to wear it i
don't think you have to wear a mask i
don't think that dude needs to wear a
damn shirt if he doesn't want it
yeah i don't care if he wears damn two
dicks to a urinal
this dude killed osama bin laden oh
that's him
that's him oh i see okay okay and also
this guy seems semi ginger you know how
hard it is for a ginger to sneak through
the dam
through you know where it get i mean it
gets pretty
you know it's more of a tan environment
over there in the desert oh yeah
everybody's got a tan oh yeah so you're
just going to lollygag through with a
damn
you know with that damn torch skin
torch skin i mean i just don't know if
this guy needs i mean
he should wear a shirt that said hey i'm
not wearing a mask because i killed
osama bin laden
yeah oh i think but for me i feel like
he gets out of jail free
yeah and i don't i mean
i wear a mask just to i guess respect
other people but if oh totally
if someone comes if i'm in the grocery
and someone's not i'm not
i don't say anything or freak out no no
i'm not a man yeah i'm not some kind of
mask warrior no no
yeah we're not the mask police no i'm
not the mass police i'm not even a man i
don't want to be
i'm not even a damn mask parole officer
you know
yeah like i have certain feelings about
the whole
uh pandemic and everything but i wear a
mask it's like somebody it's like
shaking somebody's hand when you meet
them
and if you feel comfortable after that
if people choose not to then that's
between them
yeah i think it's between consenting
adults almost kind of
agree um but i think it's for me this
guy killed bin laden
i think this dude doesn't have to wear
damn shoes into a freaking 7-eleven if
he doesn't want to
you know i'm saying i think he can go
high on the hog as he wants